don't get it messed up  russ is one of the best players our  league has ever seen and there's still a  ton left in that tank i don't know why  people tend to try to write him off i'm  going to approach him like i do every  player i've ever encountered we're going  to talk about our running habits with  the ball without the ball and again the  the team the rhythm of the team and and  trying to establish a rhythm  with lebron russ a.d don't get it messed  up  russ is one of the best players our  league has ever seen and there's still a  ton left in that tank i don't know why  people tend to try to write him off i'm  going to approach him like i do every  player i've ever encountered we're going  to talk about our running habits with  the ball without the ball and again the  the team the rhythm of the team and  trying to establish a rhythm  with lebron russ a.d